in late February supporters of Amrit
Paul Singh armed with swords and sticks
stormed a security complex in the
Northwestern Indian state of Punjab and
forced authorities to release one of his
aides
Singh is a separatist leader and
self-styled preacher who has revived
calls for an independent Sikh Homeland
police accuse him in his AIDS of
attempted murder and creating Discord in
a part of the country which still Bears
the scars of a separatist movement in
the 1980s
one that demanded the creation of an
independent Sikh State called khalistan
and prompted authorities to launch a
military operation that killed thousands
of people
kanwar pal Singh leads a separatist
organization in Punjab called dalhasa he
says many in the state were taken aback
by how quickly he rose to fame
most of the punjab's population is
surprised and because the timing
and in the very short period he has he
has he has come into the
a limelight
Singh who attended this rally last month
is now on the Run
with security operations stepped up
thousands of paramilitary soldiers have
been deployed to the state which is
majority seek so far dozens of people
have been arrested
some Sikh leaders say many people in
Punjab may still know very little about
Amrit pal Singh but his message has
started resonating
the government is not providing enough
employment opportunities these
unemployed youth have to go somewhere
thus they started supporting him
meanwhile it's not just security
officials who are growing more concerned
the government has suspended mobile
internet services in some regions that
means customers at fuel stations like
this can only pay with cash business
all business establishments have seen
their sales have common people have also
been affected some have had to borrow
money since the ATM and debit cards
aren't functioning
while the Sikh fight for independence
that began in the 1980s had been crushed
by the 1990s authorities in India still
worry about potential agitation
particularly among members of the Sikh
Community abroad
political analyst jagroup Singh sekon
says it will be interesting to see who
will be willing to join the movement
going forward
there are lots of protests in the
diaspora that happened in England it
happened in other places the idea is
come back into the Limelight but the
thing is how much support do they have
here kalistan has to be created in
Punjab other people of Punjab ready for
it or will the powerful Indian State
allow it to happen over here
questions that only seem to be
multiplying as tensions rise and a
Manhunt continues